so caiman guess what type of person is
the most likely to book and then stay in
a service department got any ideas
tourists suitor tourists yeah
tourists I mean that would be the
obvious one wouldn't it people are going
on a holiday to an area personally if
I'm traveling on holiday I do tend
especially fond yeah I do tend to use it
on my own I don't for my own I want to
go to a hotel but if I'm with the family
from going on a holiday then a service
department is pretty attractive cuz I
absolutely hate sleeping in the same
room as my kids and you know what I'm
talking about especially when you got
little kids it's really annoying they
were up all the time and then and then
you can't leave them obviously so you've
put me to bed at 7:00 you're just
sitting there in the room light in the
darkness swimming in the bathroom
reading a book or something whereas even
the service department you can stick up
in their own room and you're okay makes
sense so tourists
however tourists are actually quite low
down on the list still an important
market but I think their fourth fourth
biggest market so still someone you want
to go for so who might live of tourists
what else businessman businessman number
one
[Music]
who said that
you can slap me later or something
that's fun I was just repeating him I
was just repeating him business
professionals is what he meant business
people you are correct business people
people traveling for business that is
the number one sort of market the number
one people that you want to attract okay
so maybe when you're looking for an area
maybe you want to pick somewhere where
they might be going where where the
business people travel what hotels that
where might their meetings be what might
they were traveling for this is your
biggest market so you choosing a city
once you're the city center where
business happens that makes sense what
else
business people tourists contractors
contractors is the second biggest so
let's say for example you've got an
asset for example you've got to look at
a load of builders that are going to a
job in Liverpool and they need somewhere
to stay they use places like Airbnb to
put their accommodation what's the
problem with this market
short actually longer-term in many cases
could be a couple of weeks actually
could be a bit longer term than but
trash that then the normally pretty
respectful but here's the thing there's
a thing are you doing rent Sorrento you
should watch why you doing it to make
what money when they're booking
accommodation for a contractor they want
they want the lowest price that they
don't care about things like want sweets
and you know they only paying like you
know twenty five quid a night per person
type prices so your problem with with
them is it might not be your market
because your market I would suggest
going a bit more upmarket and going for
like nice accommodation and focusing
more on the tourists and the business
people rather than the contractors but
it depends on the property that you find
but you very much competing on price so
we've got business people contractors
tourists what else
students or students bang spot on who
said that yet if you give her a hand the
successful heart will give her a hand
fantastic relocation relocation you've
sold your house you've got your new
house going through you need a bit time
to get everything sorted what do you go
for to go for a hotel or to go for a
serviced accommodation order record
service combination yes that's a big one
as well and again they're gonna want to
look nice okay so the biggest thing we
take away from this is the easier people
so make sure you're in an area that
attracts those people so if you can know
it like burning on for example sure I've
mentioned them earlier Lia and Cheryl
Miller making the loads and money from
service departments and firming and
Birmingham is brilliant because it's not
too expensive but also there's lots of
disco Bri world there's the Sea Life
Centre there's all this sort of stuff
that attracts tourism and at the same
time there's loads of businesses so it's
attracting both markets that makes sense
that's the first thing so you're gonna
be looking in the area gonna be looking
for I would recommend a city centre that
attracts both tourists and business
people so it's got a bit of both Oh
sports events anything like that so
Liverpool I know a lot of people don't
got to doing them in Liverpool killing
it in Liverpool okay people go for the
football and all sorts of stuff so
that's the kind of thing
[Music]
[Music]